yeah schizophrenia is a genetic disorder
nobody knows what the genes are or how
they work but it's pretty clear there's
a genetic component if you can find the
Jews figure out what they do and come up
with real good treatments if lectures
for schizophrenia and possibly
Prevention's for schizophrenia that
indirectly is going to help to alleviate
the homeless problem right so I don't
know what to do about the homeless but
if you can figure out what to do about
schizophrenia that's gonna have some
impact on that yes it's basic yeah well
use you know your claim to some degree
is that these more complex social
problems should be decomposed into
isolated or micro problems and that
specific solution should be sought for
them and now that certainly strikes me
as an appropriate approach because
everybody is different not everyone is
for the same reason no no well that's
for sure that's for sure not everyone's
poor for the same reason any stretch of
the imagination that's right poverty is
doesn't have one cause no one please 50
and it's not merely caused by lack of
money either because that would be a
much easier problem to solve
unfortunately it's not so simple so the
one thing that we're probably getting
toward the end one thing I would like to
leave your listeners with is really
optimism these are not dismal problems
in perpetuity because the genetic
approach I think and I've been kind of
out you know I'm kind of out there on
this this is not a mainstream view but I
think the more something is genetic the
more likely it is we can change it for
the good and that's why we just should
study the genetics of intelligence
that's why I hope genes have more to do
with it that environment